[Music]
Monday was dr. Martin Luther King jr.
day and as is the case with almost
everything lately virtually everyone on
social media seemed to parse out MLK's
words for whatever narrative they're
currently pushing in our modern times I
saw articles on how MLK was the first
environmentalist how he was an ardent
feminist a communist a socialist and
much more the one quote I tweeted of his
is perhaps his most famous I have a
dream that my four little children will
one day live in a nation where they will
not be judged by the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
I believe this quote to be as relevant
now as it was in the early 1960s but for
a whole other set of reasons in the
1960s MLK was fighting for equality
under the law and equality of
opportunity two things that we should
all absolutely believe in today those
who judge people by the color of their
skin and not the content of their
character are fighting not for equality
but for special treatment of some at the
exclusion of others this misguided
principled thinking you should treat
someone differently because of their
skin color or thinking someone should
believe what you think they should
believe because of their skin color or
any other immutable characteristic is
the essence of prejudice which means to
prejudge this is the complete reverse of
what MLK stood for and sadly this way of
thinking has infected the modern left
almost completely this is why I like
myself so many of you find yourselves on
the outside of a political bubble that
you were once safely part of for this
direct message though I don't want to
focus on the flaws of identity politics
instead I want to focus on one of the
other topics I just mentioned socialism
and for the purposes of this message I
want to put aside whether MLK was a
capitalist or a communist or a socialist
or a hybrid of any of them what I want
to discuss is some of the reaction
around the word socialism itself the
amount of people I see talking about
socialism positively is actually
staggering a tweet I set out saying
socialism is
cool even got me into a little exchange
on Twitter with the official verified
Socialist Party who explained to me that
socialism has actually never been tried
which is why we don't know if it'll work
yet perhaps they should tell that to the
people of Venezuela right now who were
fighting for food and basic services as
they watch their socialist system
collapse on top of them the ideas of
socialism that the means of production
distribution and labor should be owned
controlled and regulated by the
community as a whole are the worst sort
of collectivist ideas which exist the
very implication that the group knows
what is good for the individual that we
exist to do things for the greater good
is totally antithetical to the purpose
of being human it's your job to find
value in your work to strive for more
than you have to bring good to yourself
and the people around you and to live as
a free person as you see fit the very
idea that you should set aside your
individuality for the community as a
whole which virtually always turns into
an intolerant hostile mob is exactly why
so many have died in socialist regimes
despite the obvious failures of
socialism socialists have no problem
using the freedoms of capitalism against
itself this is perhaps the most perverse
part of the socialist worldview much
like Islamism socialism wants to use our
freedoms against us until it attains
complete power for example they use the
tools of Twitter and Facebook companies
created through the ingenuity of
individuals and the freedom of
capitalism to attack the very system
that they often live in by the way I'm
all for them being able to do this even
if I don't like what they're doing
that's the tricky part of freedom it
even applies to people and ideas you
don't like just think for a moment if we
had a socialist government in charge
right now how do you think it would be
going for free expression and free
speech how tolerant would they be of all
the people that they label Nazis and
bigots whatever you may think of Donald
Trump and the evil capitalists are they
the ones coming for
anyone's speech right now reporters
being put in jail actually President
Obama used the Espionage Act to put a
record number of reporters in jail and
as far as I know Trump who dislikes the
press to put it mildly hasn't put anyone
in prison for the crime of journalism
fortunately I see a rising tide in
America based on liberty freedom and
individual choice note how those words
themselves are somehow thought of as
evil in the socialist lexicon liberty
freedom and individual choice must all
be sacrificed for the greater good but
what they're not telling you is that the
greater good is usually for the tiny
minority in the elite protected class
their ideas have never worked and will
never work because a system built on
stripping our humanity is in direct
conflict with what it means to be human
I've said it before and I'll say it
again this perfect system which they
wish to create can never be perfect
because we humans as flawed as we are
are part of it imperfect beings cannot
create a perfect system but what we can
create is a system that always does its
best to further the advancement of human
freedom for all its flaws this is what
capitalism is which is why if you're
watching this from a capitalist society
you should consider yourself one of the
lucky ones of course in America
politicians don't outright call
themselves socialists they say that
their Democratic socialists this is
Bernie Sanders mantra as he calls for a
revolution of every kind to be a
political social or even environmental
whatever that means what Bernie forgets
or intentionally obfuscates is that the
Democratic part of this of course will
always be tossed away as socialism takes
root it's also why there's no doubt in
my mind that eventually the social
justice movement will turn on Bernie
himself and I think there's already
plenty of evidence of that democracy is
the enemy of socialism and Bernie's
trying to have it both ways there's also
a reason that the social justice
movement has such a socialist strain
within it both of these movements based
on frowning on achievement and
accomplishment and a resentment of
those who break the mold need people to
be oppressed or at least believe that
they're oppressed to survive creativity
free thought and the pursuit of your own
happiness is the antidote to both social
justice and socialism it's either that
or a life of bitterness resentment and
jealousy which in my view is less
socialism and more just anti-social
[Music]
you